you know that visualpolitik is one of
the few political channels that pays a
lot of attention to latin america one of
the least covered regions in the world
perhaps that is why many of you have
often asked us to talk more about latin
america well
we've got a solution
[Music]
we're proud to present latam politik a
newsletter that we have prepared
together with geopolitical consulting
firm
perch perspectives if you subscribe
every month you will receive
12 newsletters with the best information
and analysis
on latin america to keep you up to date
and better understand everything that is
happening in this region the cost
you can subscribe for less than 35 cents
per newsletter
less than a small taco or a donut a week
in return
you'll be kept up to date on all major
happenings in the region and better
understand
all the possible implications in
addition all of you who support us at
patreon level four and five
will receive latin politic at zero cost
you can find all the info
at latimpolitik.com
[Music]
from new iphones with 5g capabilities to
the latest warplanes such as the f35
semiconductor chips have become the
backbone of new technologies these chips
are at the core of new industrial trends
such as for example robotics
nanotechnology autonomous driving
5g and digital ecosystems
getting hold of faster thinner and more
powerful semiconductors will be the key
to determining the outcome of many of
the great economic business and
geopolitical clashes of our time
controlling the manufacture of the most
advanced ships may be the 21st century
equivalent of controlling the oil supply
in the 20th century and no
i am not exaggerating the country the
power that succeeds in becoming the
technological leader in the
semiconductor race will be in the best
position to overtake the military and
economic power of
any other power in the same way
companies that manage to get their hands
on the latest chips will be in the best
possible position to dominate their
chosen markets
semiconductors are no longer just
components
but strategic resources that all major
economies
must secure marisa liu analyst taiwan
economic research institute
as you can imagine we are talking about
an issue that is generating enormous
geopolitical tension between the two
great powers of our world the united
states
and the people's republic of china
without digging too deep a large part of
the u.s government's sanctions against
huawei
focused on preventing the company's
access to the world's most modern chip
manufacturing technology
that of taiwan's tsmc but let's not get
ahead of ourselves in order to
understand this business
the first thing we need to know is that
there are three major types of
semiconductor companies
first of all there are companies such as
intel samsung or micron that design and
manufacture semiconductors in their own
factories
then there are other companies such as
qualcomm nvidia or even recently apple
that designed their own processes and
ships but in order to save costs they
outsource the manufacturing to other
companies such as those that make up the
third group those specialized in
semiconductor fabrication plants known
as fabs or foundries
these are companies whose main business
is manufacturing chips designed by
others
or in collaboration with others this is
the case for example of tsmc the world's
largest dedicated chip manufacturer
whose semiconductors are found in all
types of equipment
smartphones tablets servers consoles
wearable devices
automobiles and almost all high-tech
weapon systems developed in developed
countries
[Music]
and having clarified this point the
other aspect we also need to keep in
mind is that
right at this very moment at the
beginning of 2021 the world and the
major companies are facing a demand for
chips that is much greater than the
supply
[Music]
it's been a long time since we have
witnessed such a large shortage of
semiconductors and components
the lead time for some chips is up to 12
months
andrew chen ceo of kimpo electronics
february 24th 2021 biden orders broad
supply chain overhaul amid chip shortage
the president signed an executive order
aimed at finally increasing domestic
production
of critical materials wall street
journal but perhaps the area where the
impact of this growing chip shortage is
being felt the strongest and where we
can best see its consequences
is precisely in one of the industries
that has been hardest hit by the
pandemic
the automotive giants listen up
on the waiting list it's no joke
global chip shortages are forcing major
automakers to slow or even halts
production of many models
think of semiconductors as increasingly
important components in modern cars they
are responsible for making electronic
systems work
from the central computers that manage
the power of electric or hybrid engines
to driver resistance functions and
navigation systems most modern cars are
increasingly becoming computers on
wheels and in fact it is estimated that
electronics currently account for around
of a vehicle's value and that is why the
chip shortage is causing a lot of
headaches in the industry for example
companies such as volkswagen ford
honda nissan and daimler mercedes to
name but a few have had to reduce their
car production
in the same fashion the british
financial information and analysis
company ihs market has estimated that
during the first quarter of 2021 alone
the chip shortage will reduce production
by approximately 700 000 vehicles
worldwide other sources
such as morgan stanley put this figure
at 1.5 million for the whole of 2021.
in total according to alex partners the
chip shortage could cost the automotive
industry as much as 61 billion dollars
in 2021
now the question that comes up is what
has happened how did it get to this
point
[Music]
you see when the sas coronavirus ii
pandemic forced the major automakers to
hulk production
causing the largest shutdown of car
factory since world war ii their demand
for chips plummeted however during the
summer of 2020 as restrictions were
eased demand recovered faster than
expected largely due to low interest
rates and stimulus plans put in place by
governments around the world
so as production returned to its former
levels a problem arose
the gap left by the automotive companies
in the chip factories had been filled by
the giants of consumer electronics
such as apple samsung microsoft and all
kinds of companies producing smartphones
game consoles computers and a thousand
and one different gadgets
companies that were having a very good
2020 not least because of the social
distancing measures that force consumers
to stay home
the problems were uncovered days before
christmas 2020 when companies such as
volkswagen
nissan fiat chrysler and daimler began
to report production problems
many governments even decided to take
matters into their own hands and put
pressure on the world's leading
manufacturers through diplomatic
channels
all the chipmakers production lines are
already running at full capacity
and some are even overloaded we have
come to the agreement that our
chipmakers will do their best to support
automakers in the u.s
europe and japan as there are many jobs
involved and this industry is crucial to
the world
economy taiwan's minister of economic
affairs
and makes no mistake talking about
semiconductors means talking about
taiwan particularly tsmc the taiwan
semiconductor manufacturing company the
world's
largest specialized manufacturer a
leader in manufacturing technology and
only one of three companies worldwide
that can produce cutting-edge
semiconductors listen up
the most important fab in the world
dsmc is the world's largest third-party
chip manufacturer this company is
for example the only manufacturer of
processors for iphone and the only
company that also manufactures the new
m1 processors for mac computers one of
the cupertino company's biggest bets
it's also a major supplier to companies
such as qualcomm nvidia and virtually
every other major chip developer you
want another example it's plants
manufactured chips designed by the
american company zlinx that plays a key
role in the electronics of the f-35 the
latest dual in the crown of the us air
force
the fact is that tsmc's factories are
currently running at full capacity and
the company is working flat out to
increase its capacity
cranes trucks excavators and all kinds
of heavy vehicles are working around the
clock day and night
weekdays and holidays in order to expand
the taiwanese giants production
facilities during 2021 the company has
set
itself the goal of opening new research
centers increasing by 70
its manufacturing capacity for 5
nanometer chips currently the most
advanced in the world
and completing its new 3 nanometer cheap
production plant which
is due to start operations in 2020 in
the city of tainan in southern taiwan
to give you an idea it's capex budget in
investments for 2021 amounts of about
28 billion dollars that's almost three
times more than its investment in 2018
and 60
more than in 2020.
as we have already told you the chip
sector is in full swing and that
obviously has a direct impact on the
bottom line
to top it off the company has just
announced that during the period 2020 to
2025 it expects its revenues to grow at
an
annual rate of between 10 and 15 per
year this is almost double its previous
forecast
a record that could be substantially
higher if some cutting-edge projects it
is working on go ahead for example it is
working hand-in-hand with apple to
develop a new type of micro oled display
built directly on chip wafers for use in
upcoming augmented reality devices
[Music]
and all this explains why in the last
five years alone its share price has
multiplied by more than five
just in the last year the fab shares
have appreciated by 140 percent
this translates into a market value of
nearly 600 billion dollars tsmc has
become one of the 10
largest companies by market cap in the
world we are talking about a situation
that is fully impacting taiwan's entire
economy
[Music]
an island in full bloom
this small island of just 24 million
inhabitants has placed itself at the
epicentre of the new global technology
race during 2020 taiwanese semiconductor
production grew by more than 20 percent
to more than 107.5 billion dollars
to put this in perspective almost 25 of
the entire global semiconductor business
is located on this island thanks to tsmc
and many other companies that make up a
very advanced ecosystem that accounts
for approximately 15
of taiwan's gdp but taiwan has not only
become a crucial link in the global
supply chain it's also taken the lead in
making the thinnest
fastest and most powerful ships
to give you an idea despite the pandemic
which incidentally caused only nine
deaths thanks to the quick reaction of
the government as soon as the crisis was
detected in wuhan taiwan's gdp expanded
by nearly 3 percent
in 2020 while wages and exports broke
all-time records
real estate transactions grew at a rate
of more than 30 percent and according to
the real estate research agency cushman
and wakefield no less than 50
of transactions involved the acquisition
of land plants and buildings by
high-tech manufacturers and it is
precisely
the boom in semiconductors that has led
to even better forecasts for 2021.
take a look taiwan raises gdp growth
forecast for 2021 to
six 4.64 percent nikkei asia so there
you have it
this is one of the hottest markets in
the world but take note because at the
same time that
taiwan and its companies have managed to
position themselves as world leaders the
large economies such as the united
states and china are now fighting
hand-in-hand
in what has already been described as
the chip war
[Applause]
for example u.s congress is considering
fronting at least 25 billion
to support local production not least
because it is estimated that a problem
with taiwan's fabrication plants could
cause serious problems in the defense
and consumer electronics industries
two of the pillars of the us economy in
the same vein the federal government has
agreed to tsmc
investing 12 billion dollars in a new
plant in arizona that will manufacture
chips for the us military
[Music]
china the world's largest chip buyer is
involved in a 100 billion dollar plan
that beijing has put on the table in a
bid to win this kind of technological
war a plan that has allowed it to
increase its
presence in ship manufacturing but with
a quality level that is still
far from that of taiwanese or south
korean companies
anyway i hope this video has allowed you
to get a closer look at the new global
competition for semiconductor dominance
and to better understand what is going
on in the semiconductor industry in
upcoming videos here on the
visualpolitik channel and together with
value school we will talk about the
great us chip manufacturer intel and
many other interesting topics so don't
forget to like and subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already done so
all the best
we'll see you next time if you want to
learn more about politics and world
affairs and hear some more of my lovely
voice
come check out the reconsider podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at
www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple or
google play or your favorite podcatcher